Bonne année 2018 !
Merci d'avoir été aussi nombreux à vous
mobiliser pour cette pétition. Vous êtes
déjà douze à avoir signé. Je suis très
très émue, c'est vachement bien.
C'est comme ça qu'on va pouvoir faire ployer
le lobby des minéraux et c'est ça qu'on
veut, parce que ce moyen mnémotechnique
pour se souvenir de la dureté
c'est vraiment euh... c'est révoltant.
Donc youpi.
et comme je ne suis pas Nigel Farage, je ne vais pas
juste vous abandonner après que vous ayez dit non.
Je vais vous proposer une solution
alternative.
Et pour ça, j'ai été fouiller toute la
littérature scientifique
de la science de la mnémotechnique.
Mais avant, il faut
que je vous parle d'un homme.
Cet homme, c'est Georges Frandsen.
C'est un américain qui a la plus grande
collection de coprolithes connue à ce
jour. Il en a plus de 1200.
Sa pièce maîtresse s'appelle "Precious".
C'est un caca fossile qui remonte
à plus de 20 millions d'années.
Mais surtout, George Frandsen
n'a rien à voir avec notre histoire.
Donc nous disions, le
meilleur moyen mnémotechnique
pour se souvenir de la dureté des minéraux.
Pour ça je propose de passer en revue
les différents critères qui font un bon
moyen mnémotechnique.
C'est parti.
(Musique pop reprise à l'harmonica
de façon dissonnante)
donc l'idée c'est de faire naître des
images en faisant appel à son
imagination puis de les lier entre elles,
ces images donc ces informations,
par le biais de l'histoire qu'on raconte
et de rendre ces histoires marquantes
grâce aux émotions
et eeeeeeeeeeeuh
(glousse)
(grince)
... Et en convoquant les cinq sens.
Donc le principe c'est en gros de
créer des faux souvenirs pour que les
vrais puissent s'implanter.
Partant de là,
je vous propose ce moyen mnémotechnique.
un bébé avec les fesses talquées, va
voir un gipsy qui est en calcif
parce qu'il fait chaud et lui dit "regarde,
regarde mon téléphone"
"regarde ce que j'ai trouvé c'est trop bien",
et lui montre l'appli Face App.
Donc le gypsy lui dit "ouah c'est trop
beau, viens on essaye avec une photo de
Jean-Michel Aphatie et donc ils
prennent la photo de Jean-Michel Aphatie
et ils appliquent le filtre vieux. Et là, en fait,
c'est juste le même Jean-Michel Aphatie.
Simplement, il a une orthèse à un bras et
il a une montre à quartz.
Voilà donc ils se marrent bien, quand soudain
arrive dans la pièce Adriana Karembeu
elle-même qui est topless
et qui dit "oui bonjour je viens
faire la quête pour mon association caritative"
"On est pauvres, encore un don !"
Et donc le gypsy qui tombe
complètement fou amoureux d'elle
lui offre son plus beau trésor
et il sort de sa poche... un diamant.
voilà donc ma petite histoire pour se souvenir
de la dureté des minéraux.
Je vous invite maintenant à
faire pause sur cette vidéo
(enfin après que j'ai fini ma phrase)
et à essayer de répéter vous-même
la petite histoire
en essayant de vous rappeler des minéraux
qui vont à chaque étape.
J'attends.
Chut !
Si vous avez fait pause et que vous avez réussi
à vous souvenir de l'histoire, c'est bien.
Si vous avez fait pause et que vous n'avez
pas réussi à vous souvenir de l'histoire,
c'est mal. Je vous invite à revenir un
petit peu avant vers une minute 13
et à essayer de vous repasser l'histoire et de la
répéter. Si vous y arrivez...C'est bien.
Si vous n'avez pas fait pause
du tout, c'est très bien parce que ça
prouve que vous ne vous laissez pas
dicter votre vie par une vidéo youtube.
Et maintenant, allez me donner des sous
sur Utip.
Mais c'est pas tout de se souvenir
de l'histoire maintenant.
Ce qui est bien c'est de se souvenir
durablement de l'échelle de dureté
des minéraux, c'est un truc qui nous sert
tous les jours dans la vie quotidienne.
Ce que recommande la science c'est de
remobiliser ses connaissances, donc de
répéter la petite histoire,
Une heure après le premier apprentissage,
puis un jour après, puis une semaine après,
puis un mois après et enfin six mois après.
Donc revenez me voir dans six mois et
parlez-moi d'Adriana Karembeu topless.
Voilà donc tout ce système là...
Il est dégueulasse l'objectif !
Ce système pour euh de mémorisation...
(rires) Je crois que je vais la refaire celle-là !
Ce système de mémorisation
fait appel à notre mémoire épisodique.
Notre mémoire épisodique, c'est ce
qui se base sur nos souvenirs intimes.
donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait appel
aux émotions et aux sens.
Le principe, donc, c'est de transférer
progressivement ses souvenirs
de la mémoire épisodique à la mémoire sémantique,
celle qu'on utilise le
reste du temps pour parler au quotidien.
Par exemple, c'est celle qui me permet
de dire aujourd'hui que
Paris est la capitale des gros c--
Pourquoi commencer par la
mémoire épisodique ? C'est parce qu'elle
est plus facile d'accès même si elle
est moins fiable donc c'est pour ça que
c'est une bonne porte d'entrée mais
c'est bien après de transférer ça vers
la mémoire sémantique et donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut répéter et répéter et
répéter le moyen mnémotechnique.
(Musique vieux rock)
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo et pour
finir, une petite plage musicale
pour se détendre.
(Bruits de bouche)
(Musique rock)